Oh
Wow
because we play yeah they go still treat
us like they think they can just treat
us like we're not back but not all equal
you understand what I'm saying it
shouldn't be about your color your skin
and shitting be a mountain under there
it should be the fact that you are
policing you should be what to protect
because you are Sybil you're doing this
to work you should be wanting to protect
us not harm us the right if after you
going to harm me why would I want to
call you
I've seen a sign of the day that says
poor conditions makes poor decisions you
know it's true like how can we expect
children to want to grow up and not be a
product of their environment when you're
putting them in the cold
here today because it's election season
I'll be here today because exciting